el candidato presidencial de la
izquierda Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
parecía estar a un paso de la victoria
en la primera vuelta electoral sin
embargo con solo 5 puntos porcentuales
de diferencia su rival de extrema
derecha al presidente Jair bolsonaro se
encuentra en una posición Igualmente
fuerte Lula no ha perdido el tiempo y
convocó una reunión estratégica para
vencer a su rivaldo
No necesitamos hablar con gente que ya
conocemos con gente que sabemos que ya
nos ha votado con gente que sabemos que
nos va a votar
hablaremos con aquellos que no parecen
gustarnos que no parecen botarnos que no
parecen gustar a nuestros partidos y es
con ellos Con quienes hablaremos
a pesar de quedar en segundo lugar El
presidente ayer por su Naruto sorprendió
a muchos después de que su partido
ganará 99 escaños en la cámara baja y 13
en el senado con la mayor ya
conservadora en el congreso por su
Naruto su determinación de superar a
Lula en la carrera final
los adversarios solo se han preparado
para una carrera de 100 metros nosotros
estamos preparados para una maratón
lucharemos con confianza y con fuerza
creciente seguro que prevaleceremos por
la patria por la familia por la vida por
la libertad y por la voluntad de Dios
ambos candidatos no solo tendrán que
mantener su impulsor sino también
convencer a los 31 millones de
brasileños que no votaron en la primera
vuelta para que imitan un voto a su
favor
Lula y Naruto se enfrentarán en un
debate televisado que podría ser
decidido antes de la segunda vuelta
final